it's a hard question and and we don't
understand enough about it so whatever I
say is my thinking and it's speculation
more than anything but in terms of the
laws of nature making reference for
something eternal is reference to time
so I find that difficult to follow
because I think laws of nature are
fundamental independently of space and
time so we can say laws of nature are
universal
rather than eternal and in terms of the
other view that laws of nature are
encoding of whatever order we observe
around us again encoding makes reference
to language and and it can be
mathematics or it can be human language
but that is just a description of that
principle that we call law so tying up
the existence of a law and the nature of
a lot or space-time or to language i i
have trouble accepting that that part so
in my view those are fundamental and and
those that are universal meaning they do
not change and and they are true
everywhere whether in cosmos
whether it's one universe or or many
though that that's the set of
fundamental laws of course you can have
some kind of ordering that changes with
time but those would be more like pi
laws rather than the fundamental set of
laws so one one can have effective ways
of describing on average what the system
will do with time and and observe that
is changing but that kind of effective
law is more of a bylaw rather than the
fundamental law and in terms of
fundamental laws we know at least for
that describe the forces that we observe
in in the universe and and the reason
that the four forces being electroweak
gravitational and electromagnetic forces
those laws seem Universal there there is
no evidence to suggest otherwise
and and that the reason why I think that
this is fundamental laws exist in a
realm of their own independently of
space and time is because of kordell's
theorem incompleteness theorem but if
they were part of the space-time then we
would have a self referencing problem in
which case the whole machinery would
collapse
okay so laws basically their regularity
so they're just they're not very
separate
they're just regularities that we
imposed on nature where do you think
that the laws not only are universal but
in there are in their own realm and
independent of the language used to
describe them right and there are laws
are there but they're in this universe
right
well that's dualism which was outlawed
by Descartes basically and is making it
come back out yeah yeah well using
thinking also leads to the entropic
principles very much
you